dude the worst is when they get some kid
in there and they're like we're gonna
scare you boy
oh scare straight i'm not scared do it i
love scared straight why don't they do
it with gay kids
that's what i understand you know yeah
i think i think they kind of do i think
it might
that's scary straight though i like when
the the kid's hard oh they're like
you're gonna end up in there he's like
well i love it here
all right man and then move on to the
next did you see the part where the dude
make the made the kid comb his chest
hair
no no you never seen that clip oh bro he
said comb my hair
and it was like he was like a racist uh
white kid and his big black dude was
like punking him
and then he's like take this cone comb
my chest hair and then the kid was like
you never seen that clip oh rose they
scared the [ __ ] out of these kids though
man
work in the salon right there dude
he made that kid comb his hair it's wild
and their their go-to is like i'll make
you my [ __ ] man you're gonna be my girl
yeah
and then you say when he's like hold my
pocket yeah pull my pocket
oh damn yeah
holy [ __ ] the fact that brendan said oh
damn
let me get him [ __ ] let me get a piece
of it man
do you think you were tough right huh
[Laughter]
damn shoelaces they call me hustle man
you find the gateway
he's not taking it up in here with that
i'm gonna set this oh you trying to
touch my ass at the movies it's like you
you
yeah if you go for it right there him
the cone man making himself
right wisdom and anger management for
his issues
[Music]
there's always like
there is there was a female prison one
where they actually got on a scuffle
oh yeah teenage girl was like she's
telling me yeah she swung out cause i
can't even do [ __ ] she's like get in my
face again she gets in
and she oh yeah she's like no she goes
you want to hit me you want to hit me
and the girl was like wrong yeah yeah
that girl was gangster
dang she got well and who'd you bet in
that one nick
i i don't bet women's fight a lot unless
it's the over i'll take the over
two and a half rounds not a lot of
finishes yeah
[Music]
is